je voudrais d'abord rebondir sur la
question de l'utilité vous moi sénatrice
la gontrie pour pouvoir avoir des idées
et des estimations l'utilité de
l'application les seuls qui sont
capables de nous dire s'il est encore
utile compte tenu de la manière dont
elle fonctionne ce sont les
épidémiologistes sont les seuls ce sont
les seuls qui ont un avis renseigner
après on peut avoir une opinion mais
scientifiquement ce que je lis ce que
disent des épidémiologistes et je vous
invite à me présenter des
épidémiologistes qui dirait le contraire
si vous en connaissez c'est que cette
application elle est utile et nécessaire
y compris aujourd'hui y compris cet été
y compris cet automne et donc on peut
avoir
après il ya des discussions politiques
sur le bénéfice-risque opportunités et c
est génial madame à la montre parce que
je pense que vous avez mal lu l'étude
concernés ou alors expliquez moi en quoi
je viens à cette étude la 56 donc les
seuls qui peuvent le dire ce sont des
épidémiologistes prenons l'exemple de
l'étude d'oxford de l'impérial collège
cité par la sénatrice la gontrie qu'est
ce que dit cette étude diligentée par le
franco anglais christophe fraser elle
dit les données sont une actualisation
de l'étude a été publiée hier je les
tweets et donc vous pouvez vous y
référer si vous le souhaitez elle dit
très clairement aujourd'hui encore
aujourd'hui dès les premiers
téléchargements l'application évite des
contaminations et elle dit à partir de
56 % de la population dans un bassin de
vie à elle seule sans aucun geste
barrières sans masque sans test sans
confinement l'application met fin à
l'épidémie
elle ne dit pas que le seuil minimum
d'utilité et d'efficacité de
l'application ses 56 % elle dit c'est
son seuil maximum quelque part à partir
56% vous n'avez rien besoin d'autres
faits de faire d'autre mais le dis très
clairement par ailleurs que dès les
premiers téléchargements
ça évite des malades des hospitalisés et
des morts et je le dis de manière assez
vulgaire assez assez violente mais c'est
ce qu'elle dit d'une manière statistique
et c'est d'ailleurs assez intéressant de
regarder je vous invite vraiment à
regarder les cultes que vous citez même
les courbes entre le temps
l'impact du temps de prévenance parce
que l'utilité elle est double 1 je le
rappelle c'est le métro c'est la
rapidité
quand vous perdez un jour dans le temps
que vous prenez pour prévenir les
contacts c'est ça un impact en termes de
malades et de morts qui est significatif
je ne peux pas vous dire autre chose je
n'ai absolument je le dis parce que j'ai
lu certaines interventions qu'il
laisserait supposer qu'il y ait en fait
à travers le développement de cette
application est certaine coquetterie
technologique mais je n'ai le
gouvernement n'a aucun plaisir à
déployer cette application comme il n'a
eu aucun plaisir à confiner sauf que
sauf que les professions médicales
disent que c'est utile